so what is it about bad jokes that you
love rather you really love bad jokes I
feel that it takes a certain
intelligence the people to come up with
jokes which is stupid so stupid things I
find funny okay okay having said that
you know you're obviously in a great
place you've accomplished you know
incredible things in the movie you have
Zac Efron character who goes from
extreme highs to extreme lows
I was running what is the furthest
you've ever been from where you are
today Wow I've seen a lot of failure of
course you know when when films don't do
well in a row I do a lot of memories I
at least I did you know people write you
off and they'll be like ah Korea is done
and is finished and have you ever felt
like that though um not in my heart
because I depend a lot on my on my
talent and my merit and I know that I am
have the ability to deliver and that
sort of pushes me through but it breaks
your heart a little bit sometimes you
know or when people speculate things
about you which may not be true and I'm
not someone who goes up and clarifies
and I don't give it the importance
because I've been a public person for a
really long time but your heart hurts
and I think those are big lows my dad
dying you know like I've had a few of
those but my career has always been my
rock somehow that's something that's
great um
having said that I'm sure getting back
as a part of it as well yeah your recent
trip with UNICEF what do you want whoa
whoa I would like to see those kids and
leave that kind of impression be able to
give back and contribute again
I've been associated with UNICEF for
almost all my career now about 15 years
I've been led goodwill ambassadors in
India for ten years and now they're
global ambassador so this is my first
trip outside of India that I did and it
just I'm not someone who goes speechless
very soon and this trip really did that
for me because I was dealing with sexual
violence of children like kids under 18
one out of three children girls under 18
are somehow sexually violated in
Zimbabwe you know
our desire specially when we live in the
world that we do and with the privilege
that we do this one girl didn't get to
go to college because it's cool feels
too expensive for I was $74 it's crazy
exactly so you know when you see things
like that and I've always really
believed that not just me as a public
person or you as someone who's in the
media but just people who have privilege
we cannot forget other parts of the
world we cannot as global citizens be
like oh that's so far away that's not
happening to me
or even if you do it at home you have to
be socially conscientious I think that's
important and I've always sort of been
aware of that and so that's why giving
back has been and it's been an important
part of it for me as a public person
it's my job when I arrive in a place
like this or when I'm when I take the
time to take pictures and tell their
stories and it brings awareness to
something that people may forget and
that's my job as a celebrity or as a
public person that's what we get
associated with causes and they want us
so we're a means to an end
we're queued and I want to be used in
that way if I can help sort of bring
attention to things which people just
don't give attention to this is going to
be a hard turn but you could be any
celebrity
man or woman in a red Baywatch bikini
who would it be anyone anyone Oh
everyone I mean as well I mean more
people should wear bikinis regularly
especially hi I'm Melissa and I'm all
about bikinis and Bellinis that's my
thing come on take me out there right
now and I'll show you how to do that but
I think that okay I'm a Tom Hardy fan I
think he'd be he'd be really yeah I have
some guy I hate big I mean I need
supremely talented yeah
I think that would be he'd be great
enough in a bathing suit bikini I was
just hitting someone I think Sofia
Vergara would make some great slow-mo
run I think she would I think everything
in life should be into a ball I agree I
didn't get a little boring I thought
about it for one second another agnostic